توصف عادة بأنها شخص
كانت مراسلة شجاعة ولطيفة
كرست نفسها للإبلاغ عن
كفاح الفلسطينيين العاديين
في مهنة امتدت لما يقرب من ثلاثة
عقود
، قُتلت لأنها أرادت أن
تعطي صوتًا لسكان جنين
وجميع الفلسطينيين الذين  تعيش تحت
نير الاحتلال الثقيل ،
تم إطلاق النار على شيرين في مؤخرة العنق
في مساحة صغيرة نسبيًا
بين السترة الزرقاء الواقية من الرصاص المزينة بوضوح
بكلمة الصحافة
التي كانت
ترتديها والخوذة الزرقاء التي كانت
ترتديها عادةً من قبل الصحفيين.
بينما كانت في صحافة وقائية كاملة
تحدد بوضوح نفسها
كصحفية ، وجدت مجموعة متزايدة من
التقارير المستقلة أن شيرين
قُتلت على يد القوات الإسرائيلية.
كانت هذه كلها
منظمات محترمة ومعروفة دوليًا
تقوم بإجراء عملياتها الخاصة
التحقيق في تقاريرهم الخاصة كلها
توصل إلى نفس النتيجة ،
فهل نقترب من العدالة
لمشاركتها
لأن ابنة أختها كنت دائمًا قلقًا
عليها لكنها ستطمئنني
أننا صحفيون محميون ، لا
تقلق
ولكن في الحادي عشر من مايو  استيقظت على أسوأ
خبر في
حياتي قُتلت عمتي في
جنين الرصاصة التي قتلتها غيرت
حياتنا كلها إلى الأبد
كعائلة ، ما زلنا نحزن ونحزن
وما زلنا في حالة عدم تصديق مطلق
أن شيريننا الوحيد لم
يعد معنا
لم أتخيل مرة واحدة أنها ستكون هي
الأخبار العاجلة وليست هي التي
تتنقل في الأخبار
كل يوم منذ مقتلها في
الحادي عشر من مايو بالنسبة لي ولعائلتي ،
لا داعي للتكرار أن
الإفلات من العقاب على نطاق واسع يعزز بشكل واضح
التصور بأن مرتكبي الجرائم
ضد الصحفيين لا يواجهون أي
عواقب قضائية ، وبالتالي يصبح من
السهل جدًا إسكات
الصحفيين أو أي شخص يقوم بالإبلاغ
عن
الوقائع المحاضرة  استهداف الصحفيين على نطاق واسع من
قبل قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
يؤدي إلى قتل وتشويه أعداد كبيرة
من الصحفيين يشكل
في نظرنا جرائم ضد الإنسانية
تتعارض مع المادة 7 أ من معاهدة روما.
ما يرتكب هو جزء من سياسة الدولة
لإسكات وسائل الإعلام الفلسطينية
ما نطلبه.  أه
باختصار أه
أن
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
تفتح
تحقيقًا جنائيًا ولديهم
الأساس القانوني للقيام بذلك
فمن
الغريب جدًا أن المدعي العام
بدأ فورًا بالتحقيق في ما
يحدث في أوكرانيا
ولا حرج في ذلك لأنه
يجب عليهم فعل ذلك  ولكن في نفس
الوقت يجب أن يرسلوا محققين إلى
إسرائيل أيضًا